Nous avons protégé son identité
pour la sécurité.
- De voir cette réalité-là,
c'est abominable.
- Ce Canadien partage son temps
entre le Québec et l'Ukraine
depuis 10 ans.
Il séjournait dans la maison
de sa femme, dans le sud, quand
la Russie a lancé son offensive.
Depuis le 1er mars , il vit sous
occupation des forces russes.
- Au calendrier, 55 jours,
maintenant. Donc,
l'approvisionnement en
nourriture n'est par
l'Ukraine. Aucune nourriture,
aucun produit ne rentre dans
la ville, aucun médicament.- Ils
à préparer des repas pour
des familles en besoin,
parce qu'ils ont de la chance,
ils ont encore beaucoup
de provisions. C'est sa femme,
une Ukrainienne, qui les livre,
car lui sort peu.
Comme étranger, il est convaincu
qu'il sera arrêté.
Il est confiné dans son jardin
et son  quartier. out
contact avec les soldat russes,
qu'il a appris à reconnaître,
même quand ils ne sont pas
à bord de véhicules de l'armée.
- Les Russes ont dévalisé les
concessionnaires automobiles
locaux et patrouillent avec
ces voitures, qui, souvent, ont
aucune plaque d'immatriculation.
- S'il était encore possible
pour certains Ukrainiens
de fuir  la région moyennant
un paiement secret, il dit
que l'étau se resserre.
- Il y a beaucoup plus de stress
dans les 24 dernières heures
parce que là, vraiment, on a
bloqué les accès pour pouvoir
sortir de la ville, même si
les gens voulaient payer. Donc,
il y a des consignes de vraiment
garder toutes les populations,
où on annonce véritablement,
cette fois-ci, la mobilisation
des hommes et mêmes des
adolescents de 16 ans et plus.
Et on les met en devant des
bataillohair à chair à chair à .
C'est paradoxal, surréaliste.
- Encore plus troublant,
c'est la déportation des civils
par autocar vers la Russie.
Ce n'est plus une rumeur,
dit-il, mais l'atroce réalité.
- C'est très, très récent.
La ville avait été relativement
épargnée. Par contre,
dans les villages environnants,
par nos contacts locaux, oui,
on déplace des gens. Dans
la région de Melitopol, il y a
présentement des centres de tri,
des campements, où on sépare
les enfants des parents, des
grands-parents et des hommes,
OK. Et une fois que ce centre
de traitement-là a procédé,on l,
dans la région de Rostov. Et par
la suite, ils sont réexpédiés
dans des régions de Russie.
C'est ça. C'est t
ce qu'on peut faire vivre
à des populations en 2022.
On se croirait, c'est ça,
retourné il y a...
passés, tout simplement.
L'histoire se répète.
- Mais cette fois,
c'est sous ses propres yeux.
- Les atrocités, l
commises sont trop importantes.
C'est des gens qui ne
comprennent pas, c'est des gens.
- Il communique constamment
avec des amis médecins,
qui confirment que les gens
meurent tous les jours,
souvent de crise cardiaque
ou faute de médicaments.
- Il y a 10000 nouvelles tombes
de creusées dans les cimetières
environnants. Et il y a
certaines fosses aussi.
- La dernière fois qu'il est
allé en ville, c'était au début
de la guerre. Et la route était
jonchée de cadavres, Depuis,
son secteur est constamment
survolé  par des chasseurs,
des hélicoptères, et du renfort
est arrivé ce week-end.
- À peu près 500 à 700
équipements. Donc, j'entends
des tanks, des batteries.
- Qu'est-ce qui va vous arriver?
- Euh, écoutez, mon destin
est relié à... à la capaci
des forces ukrainiennes
à reprendre le contrôle
de la ville actuellement.
t été
repoussées, dit-il, de plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres
par l'armée russe,
né les chané les chané les chans
et les routes secondaires.
En attendant une porte
de sortie, il organiselation des
ukrainiens au Canada.
- J'ai une famille ukrainienne
que j'ai réussi à placerdans la.
Donc, ils vont avoir des enfants
qui vont grandir en sécurité
pour les prochaines années.- Mae
celui de centaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens, demeure incert